ganz sind unglaublich viel stahl hat
mich von 1 meter 50 und carlotta
gemessen
herzlich kommt sondern viele leute
herkommen zu teil zwei unserer
gemeinsamen projekten neben mir ist luca
der relativ lange und immer noch in
deutschland als luca das ist so der
spitzname bekannt ist und wir machen
jetzt zusammen teilt selection auf den
videobeitrag der dich damals quasi
bekannt gemacht hat wir haben schon ein
interview gedreht werden schon teils
reaction gedreht wird es auf jeden fall
schon mal ab bevor das video anschaut
und ganz wichtig bevor wir anfangen wenn
ihr dieses video seht ist auch auf lukas
kanal ein gemeinsames video von uns
beiden online habe ich euch in der
beschreibung verlinkt ja jetzt auch ab
da rein und fangen an adhs lautet die
diagnose der jungs alle haben sie
deshalb in der vergangenheit das
medikament ritalin eingenommen wird er
ihn ist auch so ein thema also ritalin
nimmst du wenn ich es richtig verstanden
jetzt nicht mehr
seit zehn jahren nicht mehr seit zehn
jahren nicht mehr bei ritalin ist an
sich ja auch nicht ohne oder ritalin ist
im grunde genommen der reine wirkstoff
amphetamine speed ja so und also das ist
das ist schon nicht ohne das ja vor
allem die die langzeit auswirkungen auf
den körper ist macht also beispielsweise
bei mir war es so ich habe das zeug mal
über die sommerferien
die sechs wochen abgesetzt und ich war
da halt mitten in der pubertät ich bin
in diesen
sechs wochen 5 cm gewachsen 8 class
ritalin schränkt das wachstum 15
zentimeter in sechs wochen ja die
wachstumsschmerzen kannst du dir
vorstellen hier oben wollen sie
versuchen ob es auch ohne geht aber dann
muss ich sagen war in der youtube kacke
noch viel besser weil sie daher so ein
cod zombie schrei rein gemacht haben
sagt so gut gepasst aber das ist auch
schon wieder so ein moment wo man sieht
ich habe voll auf entertainment gemacht
ja schon bestimmt heute wie ein echter
leckerbissen den kleinigkeit aus dem
interview sein interview kann er nicht
gesagt wie das centre an dass du also
diese kamera gesehen hast solltest du
auch so machen und hast auch viele
sachen in diesem beitrag übertrieben
nicht diesen einen ganz bekannten band
mit dem ausraster weil ich geschubst
hatten aber dass jetzt sie zum beispiel
das ist komplett da habe ich mir gedacht
das ist doch perfekte situationskomik in
dem moment einfach so wenn der sagt dann
neben luca mit zum kunden hin zum
arbeiten
ich finds passend wie in dem moment halt
auch meine gemüsen riesengroßes warten
ist es denn auch so also wenn jetzt
irgendjemand rita linien also man kennt
das ja von manch anderen drogen dass die
pupillen weitere wenn jetzt jemand zur
therapie ritalin hat er eine aufrichtige
untertasse ja ja also ich glaube es
müsse so sein würde sinn machen
ich bin mir allerdings nicht sich aber
sag ich jetzt mal normalen menschen
definitiv so bei adhs dann bin ich mir
nicht sicher wenn luca möchte unbedingt
wieder zur schule gehen
das ist sein großes ziel für die zeit
nach den schweizer bergen
ja heftig aber an sich war war es ja ein
gutes kapitel wie gesagt da wieder ein
thema sie im interview haben das an das
ding an sich mit der therapie wieder in
den bergen das war eigentlich gut ja
wirklich abhängen auf und hatten hat
auch geholfen durch verstanden aber auch
von diesem ritalin und so auch mehr los
zu kommen und in dieser klasse
einstellung dass der fall nämlich dabei
nicht vergessen heute so viele von uns
kennen nur das mim oder so und aber dass
da bist du ja dahinter als mensch mit
seiner eigenen lebensgeschichte und auch
mit keiner ganz einfachen und das ist es
ist wichtig auch mal sowas zu sehen
leute lukas weg geht im berner oberland
nicht immer gerade gab so gefeiert wie
schon oft im kreis doch das darf jetzt
wieder ganz groß er dreht sich oft im
kreis schwer sein also ich muß bis heute
sagen der typ der die reportage
geschnitten hat der hatte einen krassen
sind ja der hat das richtig richtig gut
gemacht hätte geht es um einen jungen
der seine mutter hin schmeißt ja ja
stimmt schon
und dann hinter diesem bonn slam diese
offensichtlicher weise hast du gerade
fetten spaß mit deinen schwertern doch
schwerst moves auch drauf nach den
schwertern muss man so sagen und dann
kommt dieses jahr wieder irgendwie was
ist der neue wände und das irgendwas
sinnvolles machst du nein die gleiche
programm samurai training einfach nicht
arbeiten
[Musik]
ein bisschen bern sammeln können wir uns
morgen beim frühstück machen aber es
gibt ja irgend so eine aufgabe nicht
sagen da muss man erstmal hinnehmen so
das ja einfach nicht
aber da muss sie erstmal überlegen auch
generell das auf einen aufgaben ein
aufgabe und auch jung genug ist es schon
schwerter in den boden zu schmal ja also
jetzt wirklich du siehst dass ich hier
schwer da habe ich eine sense nehme
das finde ich auch nicht korrekt von und
tatsächlich nach sieben wochen gelingt
es wirke zum ersten mal luca zur
gemeinsamen arbeit mit den anderen jungs
zu überreden krass aber das war jetzt
das erste mal acht wochen projekt
insgesamt sieben wochen sie jetzt ihr
vergangen und das war dann so der erste
band oder so auch so eine produktive
arbeit somit machen konntest du wolltest
ja das ist so richtig so richtig so
richtig überzeugen was noch nicht
abnehmen aber ich habe auch generell
sind alle produktiven arbeiten habe ich
bin möglich vermieden ist er alleine
denkt danach sieht seine schwächen und
leidet darunter
ich bin zusammen mit pascal der
außenseite ja das ist schon das schon
heavy alter dass das tool aber ich habe
ihnen verleiht wenn man das so sieht
hier machen du bist dann in den
situationen ja auch nicht ganz herr
seiner selbst habe in sachen die du
machst die antwort dann auch negativ
aufnehmen so zu gruppen das ist einfach
nicht ist halt ist ist auch heute
teilweise noch so
also das ist leider das problem absolut
mangelnde impulskontrolle so auch über
das was du sagst also ich habe bis heute
so beispielsweise wenn ich jetzt
emotionalisiert werden unter stress oder
was weiß ich nicht was dann dann kommen
sachen aus mir raus die ich sonst nicht
sagen würde und dann werde ich auch
immer noch teilweise sehr respektlos
heftig heftig dass er den wahlkreis zu
sehen also dass du da in den ruhigen
moment würde ich ganz klar ist
eigentlich und das ist auch eine
sinnvolle sache leute also dafür dass
man auch dieses video oder die wie das
wir gemacht haben sind vor
das macht dieses thema adhs ein bisschen
beleuchtet was ja nicht unbedingt so in
unserem alltag stattfindet noch mal
geredet man in der regel nicht drüber
wichtig auch etwa so zu sehen wie du
dich damals damit gefühlt hast und wird
die einsicht ist sofort wie weggeblasen
sobald er zu den anderen stößt dann muss
er provozieren und trifft sie mitten ins
herz
[Gelächter]
aber so beiläufig drücken so ein schlag
so fast kein weißt du was du
verschwindest einfach nur sauerstoff was
er hat aber auch wirklich er hat
manchmal echt sprüche gebracht ja also
da habe ich dann halt mal kommt die
reaktion von mir keine direkte reaktion
er steckt jedoch die provokation musste
man darauf achten das klingt original
wie oh das ist da sind wir dich nicht
ich nicht dass ein wort hat das gesagt
naja man weiß noch nicht genau wann ist
noch nicht ganz sicher was dich nicht
eigentlich bedeutet aber es sind drei
worte das steht auf jeden fall nicht
insofern kann krank wie pascal hens
waren ja wirklich das geht überhaupt
nicht
wenn du ihn auf wenn er zahnschmerzen
hat und deswegen weil es super g macht
sind unglaublich alle haben mich vor 1
meter 50
das ist das ist irgendwie anders
ausgelacht diesen bisschen genauer
dollar london schmerzen okay und ich
habe mich halt darüber lustig gemacht
weil ich mehr so das verdient jemand
dafür aus lassen dass auch zahnschmerzen
hat dafür dass er dich von 1 meter 50
jahren auf deinen schäden fallen hat
lassen wenn ich das nicht ich finde es
okay das ist jetzt eine doku aber die
hat mich darauf auch im kicker schon ein
bisschen sondern was redest du die kante
war ein meter fünfzig das war keine
kleine kante das ist auch das
unverständnis bei gesunden ja ich zeig
dir kann technisch vor augen
also das ding ist halt wirklich videos
gerade hat schon beschrieben hast hinter
jedem namen hinter ihrem witzigen video
im internet steht eine person die als
auch gefühle und gedanken habt und
deswegen vielleicht ein klitzekleines
bisschen jeden tag versuchen sich
mehrere andere da rein zu versehen und
auf wenn man von leuten nur 1 10 sekunde
ausschnitt aus dem internet kennt sind
am ende trotzdem entschied gefühl und
ihre eigene geschichte leute und lukas
kanäle sind der beschreibung verlinkt
luca vielen dank dass du dabei was hat
mich sehr gefreut dass ich mal ab ich
hatte ja vorher vorgestellt das video ab
operierte um einen kanal wissen dass
daraus macht gut